imaginemos que nos dicen que 495 es
igual a 621 menos espacio en blanco a
que será igual el espacio en blanco
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
bueno vamos a resolverlo juntos una
técnica es visualizar esto en una recta
numérica 495 es lo que se obtiene al
restar algo a 621 vamos a escribir ambos
números en la recta numérica la
dibujamos comenzamos con 621 le restamos
el espacio en blanco y obtenemos 495 si
aquí está 621 vamos a restar cierta
cantidad para llegar a 495 ahora cuál es
la cantidad que restamos aquí restamos
espacio en blanco
necesitamos encontrar que es igual este
espacio en blanco como pasamos de 621 a
495 una forma que se me ocurre es
primero restar 21 para llegar a 600 aquí
restamos 21 y llegamos a 600 luego
restamos una centena para llegar a 500
aquí restamos una centena y estamos en
y para pasar de 500 a 495 sólo tenemos
que restar otros cinco así que para
pasar de 621 a 495 restamos estos
números que elegí intencionalmente
elegir restar 21 para llegar a 600 luego
elegir restar 100 para llegar a 500 y
por último elegir restan 5 para llegar a
495 preste un total de 21 luego reste
100 y luego reste 5 lo escribimos reste
100 3 de 21 y reste 5 cuánto reste en
total vamos a escribirlo así 621
todo esto es igual a 495 en total si
restó 21 y resto 5 estaré restando 26
por lo que estaría restando 126 por lo
que 495 es igual a 621 menos 126 hagamos
otro ejemplo ahora queremos encontrar
espacios en blanco menos 435 es igual a
en esta situación aquí es igual el
espacio en blanco esto es un poco
diferente al ejemplo anterior ya que
ahora no nos piden encontrar que restar
al número más grande sino que aquí nos
piden encontrar el número más grande el
número más grande menos 435 es igual a
210 como siempre es útil dibujar esto en
la recta numérica para asegurarnos de
analizar esto de forma razonable vamos a
comenzar con blanco y le restamos 435 lo
que resulta en 210 comenzamos aquí vamos
a poner signos de interrogación para
ubicar este punto comenzamos aquí y
restamos 435 esto es menos 435 y
llegamos a 210 para encontrar el espacio
en blanco podemos hacer lo contrario
comenzará en 210 y luego sumar 435 a que
es igual 210 más 435 hay varias formas
de resolverlo y los invito a qué pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver esto
una forma de hacerlo es primero sumar
400 vamos a usar otro color para darle
variedad primero sumamos 4
si a 210 sumamos 400 nos da 610 y luego
si sumamos 30 esto nos va a dar el
dibujo no es exacto pero nos da una idea
de lo que está ocurriendo nos va a dar
tres escenas más esta decena lo que
resulta en cuatro decenas por lo que
esto es 640 y finalmente sumamos 5 si
sumamos 5 esto de aquí va a ser 645 aquí
lo tenemos 600 45 menos 435 es igual a
210 con eso terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo